in turkey the country has entered full
lockdown its strictest since the start
of the pandemic
as it fights its own battle with soaring
covet 19 cases and deaths
people have been ordered to stay at home
for nearly three weeks only allowed to
go outside for grocery shopping
and other essential needs correspondent
yulia hahn sent us this report from
istanbul
[Music]
saying goodbye a moment of calm
but only briefly
there is not much time for farewells
here in sinjalikuyu
at one of the largest cemeteries in
istanbul
while the families mourn outside
the next coffins are already arriving
the funeral home workers try to ensure
that everything is as dignified as
possible
but it has been turkey's deadliest month
since the pandemic began
and that has also become very apparent
here
[Music]
before the pandemic we had around 200
funerals per day
there are now more than twice as many
we urgently need the new lockdown if we
should have made this decision earlier
then probably fewer people would have
died
shortly before the new lockdown came
into effect
the streets and shops were full again
above all
alcohol was in great demand because from
now on there is a ban
on sales residents are only allowed to
leave their homes for essential needs
until mid-may it is not the first
coronavirus curfew in turkey
but the strictest one so far most of
public life is supposed to come to a
standstill
for two and a half weeks but many people
are wondering how they will get through
this time
as they can't hope for any financial aid
especially in the poorer neighborhoods
of istanbul
many are worried only a few have
permanent jobs
here in tarla basha most of them make a
living as day laborers
or trash collectors
[Applause]
only god knows how we'll manage but
there is nothing we can do
we will try to survive somehow
my daughter has just had a baby we are
six people living in a small room and we
already don't have enough money to live
on
of president recep tayyip erdogan say he
hesitated too long
which made the situation worse although
turkey has the highest number of daily
new infections in europe
erdogan held several party congresses
with
thousands of members of his ruling akp
in march
a few days ago he pulled the emergency
break
we must rapidly reduce the number of new
infections
to fewer than 5 000 a day otherwise we
will inevitably pay a heavy price
in every field from tourism to trade
and education a small sacrifice
says the president for a greater goal
in about two weeks at the end of ramadan
turkey will emerge from its lockdown
hoping
that its latest crisis is under control
you